Troy Vincent former NFL player NFL
executive VP of football operations
joins us on the program
I tried good morning thanks for joining
us that's your job title explain what
your job is to our audience today is
trying to get people get all football
executives coaches general managers
let's get this cat's rule right
okay he's bringing all opinions and and
just trying to get the the catch rule
right but actually I'm the I oversee the
game I have the opportunity to now be
part of the game overseeing officiating
our player engagement efforts working
with our clubs on the club
administration side so the development
development of players so that is my
role as the overseer of the game of
football making sure that the game is
played fairly that there's equity that's
in place so that each and every week
the fans doesn't matter what 32 you know
what team you root for that the game is
playing fairly with the right equity in
place I felt all along about the catch
rule that the NFL kept adding language
instead of subtracting so instead of
saying Calvin Johnson we made a mistake
you know complete the process and then
it survived the ground and it just it
felt like language from a lawyer Troy
and now it feels like maybe you guys are
starting to take away words and make it
cleaner crisper and more concise is that
a fair assessment of what's been going
on Dan you're absolutely correct and
that is the process that that we took it
was we looked at tons and tons of video
and then we just asked ourselves the
question the fan has said why isn't that
a catch it looks like a catch it smells
like a catch it feels like a catch why
is that not a catch and then we went
through from the Wayne Chrebet Bert
Immanuel Calvin Johnson Hines Ward to
the Dez Bryant Jesse James and we just
asked ourselves why would you like this
to be a catch and then we work backwards
from there and writing language that
says
if we want this to be a catch then less
right which meant to your point less is
better and simpler yeah because I even
said to Aaron Rodgers look that was a
catch by Dez Bryant and he goes no it
wouldn't I said well maybe by the rule
but the rule was you know written
incorrectly in my opinion Jesse James
was a catch
and I I think we were punishing players
for being athletic and I don't know I
don't know how we got to this point but
that to me I just thought kind of
contradicts what you want with the NFL
you want athleticism you wanted Dez
Bryant trying to score Jesse James
trying to score you know that was my
issue with that and I do think instant
replay or video replay has made it even
tougher because it's now frame by frame
I think it's it's because it's too good
slows everything down I can find fault
with just about any catch I want to know
question and replay is here is not going
anywhere when again when we began with
you look at the Wayne Chrebet play and
just look at the technology frosty looks
like it's snowing and we watch tape this
year if you we looked and looked at the
steel frames and the slow-mo shots of
the Calvin measurement we were counting
the pellets as he was dragging his feet
you can actually count the pellets
pellets that were coming off the ground
so I feel like that what the committee
is recommending it has truly simplified
where the owner a restaurant in Madison
Wisconsin or Camden New Jersey or Philly
when someone says ok what defines a
catch control - feat perform a football
act and I believe that that's with the
fans that's what the players that's what
our coaches that's what we all want yeah
commentators so control two feet perform
a football act all right here's another
thing though Troy the catch if I catch
the ball
tap-tap go out of bounds why do we care
what the football does when I get out of
bounds did I catch it
tap-tap and then I go out of bounds who
cares correct so there were three areas
that we looked at Dan when we were
evaluating and trying to simplify that
slight movement of the ball the old
language read slight movement you know
appreciate that means you got to
overturn it going to the ground and then
you had replay so
you believe two of those categories a
slight moving the ball because you can
have movement but have still maintained
control we removed and got out of the
business of slight movement because you
can have movement but still be in
control the Clemens play and the Super
Bowl was the best example yeah the ball
moved but he had complete control over
the ball through the process of the
catch
okay so right but it but this upcoming
season if you catch it inbounds
tap tap go out of bounds and the ball
goes you know maybe it's dislodged or
goes to the ground is that a catch we're
hoping that's what the committee's
proposed okay I got your back the
instant the pass interference are you
adopting the college pass interference
call bedded 15 years 15 yards spot of
the foul actually to Jess that's the
Jess proposal on it's just being a
15-yard it does have some momentum it's
been discussed in India too combines
again this past week
it does have some momentum I'm
interested in how the coaches when we
get together with the coaches dis Sunday
in Orlando I think there's going to be
some interesting discussion and debate
on the floor but this proposal from the
Jets does have some momentum the
targeting rule that we have in college
football
are we inching close closer to that in
the NFL well we have in essence we
actually have the the what college teams
is targeting inside of our unnecessary
you know the the player that gets hit in
his head and neck area is a defenseless
player we deem that time we just don't
use the term targeting but in between
our unnecessary roughness
unsportsmanlike conduct we can we
actually are able to distinguish when
that occurs that that that shot as we
say the shot or the hit to the head and
neck area but can you eject that view
you you're not ejecting that player like
we do in college no today that's not an
and we talked about it we it was healthy
healthy debate over the ejection
I mean ejecting that players were gone
we feel like the official does have the
ability to eject a player we just feel
like what we have in place is the
official has the autonomy to eject the
player for for for foul or something
that he deems inappropriate now we did
with one thing that the committee is
recommending is a non football act yeah
and that player and art McNally gameday
central in New York River on having the
ability to remove a player in this
situation like Evans in it yeah groans
wrong should have been tossed in Mike
Evans should have been tossed right yes
okay
right now that is being actually
recommended to give New York the ability
to remove a player for that non football
act not put a penalty on the field he's
Troy Vincent the NFL executive vice
president of football operations joining
us on the program any discussions of
eliminating kickoffs we talked about it
at length yesterday frankly all over the
weekend when you just look at the
medical data and I will tell you that
the the team of Jeff Miller and dr.
seals the data that we now collect with
the data to research the science and the
video tying all those things together as
you know I'm a traditionalist and many
of us in a room are traditionalists that
that the special teams play there's
three phases of the game offense defense
and special teams to just think about
the removal of not having that kickoff
kickoff return part of the game many you
know there's resistance but we
understand we're at a place college
football is adjusting high school and at
the peewee level we are going to address
some of those issues that we see in the
kickoff we're going to put a group
together immediately after the owners
meeting coming into New York and really
discuss we have to do something about
that play the spacing and the contact
that's being made on that punt punt
return the injuries both soft tissue and
head injuries that occur
the future it could be it could be
something that we really have to examine
others are doing it and we need to stay
ahead of it will there be a vote on that
to eliminate Nicholas not not not not
this particular this weekend there's not
a proposal on the floor of it we just
want to make sure that we're we
understand what is happening there and
we just do need some more discussion on
how does that how does that work is
there any other rule changes that are
being discussed that you'd like my
opinion on Troy if I can help out well
you tell me what you you tell me what
you think that we should be adjusted
where we should be headed I think you
guys have had a great off season you
finally listened to me about the catch
rule and the athletic move and Jesse
James should have been a touchdown dez
bryant should have been a catch a fumble
he recovered it I think you want to get
rid of the kick off I think the whole
onside kick is an issue there
the fumbling out of the endzone how
about that one with the pylon Troy
should we punish somebody who's trying
to make an athletic move going into the
endzone how is that being framed here
with fumbling out of the end zone and
then you lose the ball it's healthy
discussion to you do you reward the
defense you're the offense keep the ball
what are the unintended consequences
that occur some says maybe the ball
should go back to they be put on the 15
or the 20 yard line
and when your room is split it just
tells you that okay what are the
unintended consequences that could
happen if you change the rule there and
depending on offense coach defensive
coach who's you who are you given the
advantage to and we're game that that
points are important fans want to see
points scored so that's always a healthy
debate Dan I know I didn't actually give
you the answer but that's kind of how it
plays out in a room where the room
becomes split and then the question is
what are the unintended consequences if
you change it to drastic of a change
what can happen also I would let the
quarterback have the football to his
liking and make that window of how
inflated or under inflated it is make it
a little bit
more conducive to what the quarterback
wants your quarterback gets his football
my quarterback gets his football there's
no advantage there Troy what do you
think that is something that has been
that has been discussed and I think the
fans I think that's what the fans want
they want to see their quarterback with
the ball in his hand with an opportunity
to score again under his under his terms
like what we call it the Tom Brady rule
i'ma call the damn pass but I think it
have a little more impact nationally if
you called it the Tom Brady rule I don't
know if Tom would like it but I think it
would have an impact joy
well you're bringing it up and I again
it's had discussion but this is what the
fans want they want points and they want
to see their star have the ball in their
hand with an opportunity to win the game
or to score more points yeah I don't
care what the inflation I don't care
what the number is so I'd be like if
Brady wants it this way and Rodgers
wants it that way who cares
the final serious question who could
bench more you or the Commissioner I
would probably say today and yesterday
and ten years ago and 20 years myself
who could run a faster 40 oh no question
I'll give him a 10 15 yards and come
passing like he's standing still Wow
I'd like to set that up at the combine
next year Troy no you can set it up on
51st and Party where could you outrun
the Commissioner in a suit and tie in
dress shoes with a head you'd give him
ten yards and you could be able to come
in ten yards and a starting block could
you need it could you outrun the
Commissioner you going back you
backpedal okay I love this NFL Home
Office smack-talk there Troy thanks for
joining us and good luck with the
meetings there and all the decisions but
we think you're heading in the right
direction Thank You Troy that's Troy
Vincent NFL executive vice president
football operations for more dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]